non j'ai bien aimé le bol à pied de
touche vintage que vous avez apporté à
votre cv là je trouve qu'il ya un côté
créatif mais en fait c'était pas vintage
c'est juste vieux bon soyons honnêtes
vous avez menti sur votre âge et
évidement évidemment marc évidemment tu
n'en aurait jamais eu en et vous
monsieur les régions le progrès c'est
pas le problème c'est juste que ça
commence un petit peu mal la russie
responsable faire on va dérouler
l'entretien
jusqu'où la convention fait affaire
qu'est ce que c'est que ce type
d'un côté si ça peut vous rassurer
légalement parlant moi je ne peux pas
vous écartez d'une procédure de
recrutement au regard de votre âge je
veux bien mais regarder autour de nous
ils ont tout ce temps
ouais bon il est pas tout à fait sans
trop de temps oui oui j'ai compris
franck tomber je valide et là c'est bon
temps oui oui y compris dans 35 ans
alors vous convaincre qu'un candidat qui
ait de l'expérience peut apporter un
plus à votre demeure vous avez une
demi-heure par candidat au prix de
meilleur vendu aller à l'essai pour être
ton père fait un effort bon ok alors
faisons ça qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
présenter votre candidature chez nous
par contre s'il vous plaît on va avoir
une discussion d'homme
ah oui d'accord donc c'est toi qui
décide en fait oui mais moi ce stage
doit évaluer l'adéquation de vos
compétences au poste il ya quand même un
protocole à le protocole au nom lorsque
j'en viens à penser qu'à moi dimanche
chez mes parents je me prends place et
la relation client cruel la vieillesse
quand même son époque un type comme lui
de faire bouger les lignes
maintenant il est maladroit et honteux
comme l'albatros est pour ça qu est ce
que je vais je prends mon téléphone nous
attend je sors mais quand j'y pense que
j'aimerais voir ma retraite moi depuis
cinq ans d'études deux ans de stage 9 en
reste 33 ans a cotisé catastrophe même
salle clients puis vieux bientôt plus de
cheveux lem la paillette faut bien
construire revolver sortir pas d'enfant
je n'ai pas de copine les raisons que
j'ai par exemple j'ai raison
à noter qu'à faire les questions et les
réponses
allez vous invite à boire un café que là
je vais finir vieux garçon manger des
plats surgelés en attendant la mort mais
je n'ai qu'une mode internet 1
mais qu'est ce qu'ils racontent bordel
[Musique]
oui je crois que c'est vous la suis
désolé écoutez je comprends très bien ce
que vous me dites ça fait moi je veux
pas vous faire perdre votre temps on ne
recherche pas un profil de commercial
pour ce poste 2 donner moins de 2 vous
savez pour moi c'est une régression
alors vous me donnez deux ans je crée
mes points et je disparais
on va dire que c'est une prime à la
signature
[Musique]